الى زاور في موسكو زاور موسكو ستدعو لعقد
اجتماع عاجل لمجلس الامن ما التوجه الذي
ياخذه الموقف الروسي الان في اعقاب هذه
الضربات
الامريكيه نعم منذ بدايه الازمه في غزه
الموقف الروسي ياتي في سياقه المعارض لاي
تحركات امريكيه الانتقاد في اعلى لهجات
بتجاه الاداره الامريكيه وسياساتها التي
براي موسكو وهذا ما اعلنت عنه وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان صدر اليوم بشان
الضربات الامريكيه للمواقع في سوريا
والعراق بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا تريد ان تحل هذه الازمه وتريد تصعيد
الصراع في منطقه الشرق الاوسط عبر استدراج
كما وصفتها دول كبيره في المنطقه الى هذا
الصراع وان السياسه الامريكيه دائما بحسب
وزه وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه لا تهدف الا
الى تصعيد الامور كونها تستفيد من
التناقضات والصراعات الموجوده في العالم
وخاصه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه قالت انها تعمل الان مع
رئاسه مجلس الامن وايضا الدول الاعضاء في
المجلس من اجل عقد جلسه طارئه من
اجل فهم ما يجري
وال وضع الامور في نصابها سيما وان موسكو
تعتبر ان الوجود الامريكي بشكل عام ان كان
في سوريا او في مناطق اخرى هو وجود غير
شرعي كونه براي موسكو طبعا هو لم ياتي لا
بقرار دولي لا عن طريق تحالفات وافقت
عليها المنظومه الدوليه والمؤسسه الدوليه
للامم المتحده ولا بموافقه الانظمه
الموجوده في تلك المنطقه وعلى سبيل المثال
سوريا وهي بالنسبه لموسكو يمثلها فقط
النظام السوري وبالتالي الموقف الروسي
دائما منذ اندلعت ال الحرب على غزه كان
ياتي في سياق معارض لكل السياسات
الامريكيه التي تعتبر موسكو ان واشنطن
احتكرت هذا الملف ولا تريد ان تسعى الى
حله والحل براي موسكو يكمن فقط في انشاء
دوله فلسطينيه بناء على التشريعات الدوليه
تكون قادره على الحياه مع جيرانها بما في
ذلك مع اسرائيل نعم وسيرا شكرا جزيلا لك